[Musique]
nicole je n'aurais jamais imaginé que
l'urss s'effondrerait sa dette française
[Musique]
voulions pas nous séparer et nous étions
pour l'union
on était plein d'espoir que c'était la
fin du pouvoir soviétique que tout
serait merveilleux désormais tous
c'est en raison de la situation actuelle
c'est aura c
est après que je démissionne de mon
poste de président de l'urss
on aurait dû retrousser nos manches et
sauver préserver tout ce que l'union
soviétique nous avait donné
un dur je me suis prononcé sa main
fermement
en faveur de l'autonomie et
l'indépendance des peuples facebook et
de la souveraineté des républiques is
mais en préservant l'urss
l'intégrité territoriale du pays
les événements ont pris un chemin où
différents
[Musique]
on peut comparer la dissolution d'un
pays un crash d'avion c'est terrifiant
et en moins de temps fascinant est
extrêmement rare
[Musique]
on commence le décollage
ce niveau de sécurité aérienne est
désormais si élevé ce que vous avez
probablement plus de chance de vous
blesser en étant allongé sur votre
canapé à la maison que de mourir dans un
crash d'avion
dans les années 80 l'union soviétique
était comme un gros avion de ligne en
suivant son itinéraire dans un ciel
dégagé il semblait que les moteurs
fonctionnaient bien mais ces pilotes
changer trop souvent
donné trois secrétaires généraux étaient
morts d'affilée
la situation au sein de l'administration
était tendu
les élites à moitié plongé dans le
désarroi
cela allait affecter tout surtout la
gestion des affaires les gens
réclamaient des changements
et un nouveau pilote a proposé de
changer un peu de cap
il faut accélérer le développement
économique de façon à faire avancer tout
le pays
améliorer le bien-être matériel la
qualité des biens et des appareils la
construction des logements etc
en 1985 michael gorbatchev arrive au
pouvoir à l'âge de 54 ans ce nouveau et
jeune secrétaire général et est vue d'un
bon oeil par rapport à ses prédécesseurs
plus âgés et à la santé fragile
gorbatchev était énergie populaire il a
immédiatement affirmé que le pays avait
besoin de changement malgré une
stabilité apparente l'union soviétique
avait de graves problèmes économiques
le prix du pétrole qui constituait la
principale exportation vers l'occident a
fortement baissé dans les années 80 et
le pays s'enfonçait dans la course aux
armements s'efforçant de rivaliser avec
son grand rival les états unis et des
sommes gigantesques avaient été dépensés
pour de nouveaux missiles chars et sous
marins
il y avait aussi un autre fardeau
monstrueux qui pesait sur notre pays
le maintien de l' empire cela
représentait environ 40% du pnb 25 %
pour les dépenses militaires aujourd'hui
c'est 5% en plus il y avait d'énormes
subventions aux républiques la géorgie
bénéficié du plus important financement
par habitant l'ukraine recevait les
sommes les plus importantes
et enfin il y avait des subventions à
d'autres pays socialistes et d'énormes
subventions aux pays du tiers-monde
d'orientation socialiste qui ont disparu
les six qu'elle empire c'était une
grande pression au sein des grands
ensuite gorbatchev a proposé un
programme de rénovation de l'économie
nationale en crise le secrétaire général
a lancé la pérestroïka qui allait
devenir le mot le plus populaire des
années 80 dans tout le pays alors même
que sa signification n'était pas
vraiment clair pour tout le monde
la pérestroïka ça a quelque chose à voir
avec la base si les basses sont bonnes
solide vous pouvez tout simplement
essayer de reconstruire ce qui est au
dessus
tout ce que nous avons subi était dieu à
cette dangereuse est regrettable
illusion de gorbatchev
en lançant la pérestroïka il n'avait pas
de réels programmes en tête il n'a pas
su munir d'un programme ni le parti ni
son entourage politique le plus proche
c'est une personne dans les pensées sont
tout à fait décousu mal structurée nous
les soviétiques de l'époque et les
citoyens russes contemporains on ne
comprend toujours pas ce que cela
paraisse trop cas était censée signifier
qu est-ce qui devait être reconstruit en
quoi les changements initiés par
gorbatchev visait à faire éviter au pays
l'impasse économique mais en réalité les
choses ne faisait que de se détériorer
sa tentative de reconstruire l'économie
soviétique planifié aggraver le déficit
commercial le mot déficit est alors
devenu aussi célèbre que pérestroïka
les gens voient des magasins vides
tous les jours de plus en plus de
produits disparaissent
le congrès des députés du peuple a
adopté des mesures pour restaurer
l'économie
ils ont mangé l'urss avec du saucisson
c'est ça ils ont donc mis le destin de
l'union soviétique au même niveau que le
saucisson
l'idée communiste qui cimentait toute
l'union soviétique avait été sapée et
était quasiment morte la raison
principale bien sûr était que l'économie
communistes et socialistes ne pouvaient
pas assurer une vie normale pour les
gens du peuple
la pérestroïka était sa beauté ils l'ont
fait dérailler deux forces ils l'ont
arrêtée
mais ce qui a été mise en oeuvre dans le
cadre de la pérestroïka en interne
c'était la démocratie les élections
libres la liberté de religion et de
propriété privée la liberté de quitter
le pays soit moins d'avril tomorrow
la glace note était un succès cher une
réalisation qui a secoué tout le pays
les gens ou enfin senti qu'ils avaient
acquis une sorte de liberté
il comprenait que ce n'était que la
glace nost et la liberté d'expression
qui rendrait ce processus irréversible
parce que tant que les décisions sont
prises à huis clos dans les bureaux du
parti c'est une chose mais quand une
idée passionne les masses ça change tout
si on a supposons un pilote
inexpérimenté
et qu'il a par exemple fait trop
basculer la viande sur l'ale
on perd de la vitesse l'avion part sur
le côté on a une perte de vitesse et
donc un décollement du flux de l'air sur
l'ale et on commence à décrocher
gorbatchev avait deux images publiques
très différentes en occident il était
surnommé gorby il était considéré comme
un homme politique est l'esprit libéral
qui avait fait le premier pas pour se
réconcilier avec ses adversaires
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le nouveau secrétaire général soviétique
savez s'entendre avec les dirigeants
européens et américains ils savaient
leur plaire
il avait très envie de plaire à
l'occident
il était flatté par leurs loges
tchatcheur est trop disait de lui ce que
d'autres dirigeants occidentaux disent
et cela lui donnait un sentiment
d'euphorie
mais pendant ce temps en urss l'attitude
envers gorbatchev changeait les
nouvelles initiatives du secrétaire
général suscitent est de plus en plus
souvent l'agacement auprès du peuple
surtout sa campagne anti alcool le très
sobre gorbatchev instaurer la
prohibition
en 1982 personne ne s'attendait à ce que
près d'un million et demi de tonnes de
raisin soit récolté sur tout le
territoire de la république moldave
je m'en souviens bien car il n'y avait
pas assez de conteneurs à penche la
nouvelle selon laquelle gorbatchev avait
publié un décret sur la lutte contre
l'ivrognerie et l'alcoolisme est un coup
dur pour tous les citoyens de la
république moldave
surtout pour les vignerons et les
viticulteurs
parce que le décret leur ordonnait de
déraciner leurs vignes occases et la
question se pose est de savoir comment
se débarrasser des stocks de vins qui se
trouvaient dans les établissements
vinicoles
les galeries souterraines 2000 estime
ichi elles sont dans le livre guinness
des records
55 km de tunnel de cette ancienne
carrière de pierres sont utilisés pour
stocker faire mûrir le vin moldave
la plupart des vins de notre collection
sont de 86 87 ceux qui sont les plus
vieux ce n'est pas qu'ils ont disparu on
les a cachés c'est ce qu'on a réussi à
sauver
ici d'un autre cave nous n'avons pas
jeté un seul tonneaux de vin parce que
nos avions un directeur très courageux
et qui n'a pas obéi
on a creusé un local spécial jusqu'à
cent mille bouteilles de vin ont été
cachés ils ont construit un faux mur et
cacher loin derrière
nos ouvriers étaient très opposés à ce
que l'on se débarrasse du 20 au reste et
même devant les portes de la cave pour
ne laisser personne est entrée c'est
comme ça qu'on a sauvé ses vins
pour le ratio de la superficie des
vignobles par rapport à la superficie
totale du pays la moldavie occupait la
première place au monde la production de
vin était sa principale industrie en
raison de la prohibition la moitié des
vignes ont été détruites ce qui ne
pouvait que conduire à un effondrement
économique
[Musique]
les répercussions de cette loi se font
sentir jusqu'à aujourd'hui les n'avons
toujours pas réussi à reconstituer les
vignobles à la même échelle
qu'auparavant
gorbatchev prévoyait probablement d'être
le premier et seul réformateur mais il
avait déclenché une réaction qui à un
moment est devenu incontrôlable
il y a ceux qui n'arrivent pas à suivre
la pérestroïka et l'état d'esprit des
gens certains sont même à la traîne
alors qu'il faut être à l'avant garde
à la fin des années 80 un concurrent
capable de rivaliser avec gorbatchev est
apparu boris eltsine c'est un haut
fonctionnaire du parti et comme
gorbatchev il voulait des changements
mais lui était prêt à aller beaucoup
plus loin et certains croyaient déjà que
helsinn et non gorbatchev était le
principal réformateur du pays
au début elle tiny de la trecobat chef
helsinn étaient consternés par le vieux
politburo ils vont détruire le pays lui
était considéré comme jeune même s'il
avait 54 ans en 1985 c'était un
blanc-bec vous comprenez ils avaient
tous à peu près 70 ans et si une
question surgit c est qu il tenait de
prendre la parole personne ne l'écouté
ils votaient de leur côté et après lui
il monte dans la voiture et commence à
râler mon dieu mais où mène-t-il le pays
nos sombrons dans l'abyme
boris eltsine et les élites qui
s'étaient rassemblés autour de lui
voulait s'emparer du pouvoir c'est tout
à fait normal en plus il était
ouvertement anti communiste est me
semble-t-il contrairement à gorbatchev
qui était communiste un bon communiste
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps avec
helsinn il ya eu l'impression qu'il
détestait vraiment le communisme à cause
de tout ce qui avait été fait lors des
répressions etc et deuxièmement il
voulait le pouvoir
boris elstine vient de me présenter un
résumé de la réunion du cabinet des
ministres mais je ne mets pas encore lu
elise est là donc
[Applaudissements]
libéré de sa lampe le génie a refusé
d'obéir à gorbatchev la liberté de
critiquer auparavant impensable dans la
politique publique soviétique a créé
l'occasion de s'en prendre au secrétaire
général lui-même
ce sont des télégrammes de soutien du
peuple de mon grand pays de soutien à
mon appel à la démission de gorbatchev
chers camarades je fais la proposition
d'inclure à l'ordre du jour le dépôt
d'une motion de censure contre le
président de l'urss mikhaïl gorbatchev
n'a tout simplement pas l'autorité
morale pour continuer à diriger le pays
vous ne pouvez pas exiger d'une personne
plus qu'elle n'est en mesure d'en donner
michael gorbatchev a fait tout ce qu'il
pouvait ayant brisé le pays ayant tourné
les peuples les uns contre les autres il
a conduit à la pauvreté et à la
mendicité cette grande puissance
j'ai dit que gorbatchev détruisez le
pays qu'il ne menait à la catastrophe et
là des conflits ethniques
pour des promesses de l'occident
gorbatchev avait oublié de quel pays il
était président le silence régnait dans
la salle tout le monde était pétrifié en
sommes
je sais que sur 1000 voix
la mienne et celle qui ne va peut-être
pas être entendus
mais je sais aussi que ce congrès est un
ultime espoir du peuple désolé terminée
excusez moi mais je soumets une
proposition non arrêté camarades ou mal
à tout va il vous reste deux minutes
très bien alors laissez-moi m'exprimer
s'il vous plaît il ya un nouveau stoppé
quand j'ai terminé je suis retourné à ma
place il était assis là et pleurer des
hommes qui pleurait
il avait des larmes aux yeux mais
personne n'osait se lever et dire quoi
que ce soit et lorsque j'ai réalisé qu
aucun d'entre eux n'a les faire quoi que
ce soit je me suis levé pour protester
et j'ai dit je ne peux pas continuer à
travailler au soviet suprême tant que
cet homme sera président je démissionne
donc en tant que membre du soviet
suprême
le moteur droit a pris feu on initie des
procédures d'extinction d'incendié et on
continue de voler avec un seul moteur et
puis il ya des rafales de vent et vous
pouvez commencer à paniquer
[Musique]
l'abkhazie est une région au bord de la
mer noire elle était autrefois une
importante station balnéaire soviétique
officiellement l'abkhazie faisait partie
de la république socialiste soviétique
de géorgie même si sa population était
principalement abkhaze maisons sont
m'inquiétais pas trop en urss quelles
frontières intérieures nous sommes un
seul et même pays mais au milieu des
années 80 avec elle à glace noste la
liberté annoncé par gorbatchev
on a commencé à parler de l'indépendance
de la république est what what else toi
c'est dans cette situation là nous avons
vu les nationalistes les plus extrêmes
commencé à relever la tête en géorgie
d'internât lester
[Musique]
2 oui voilà bon travail comme ça voilà
c'est ça avancer et reculer en va et
vient ne laissez pas le ballon vous
échappez d'accord
cette équipe là celle de dole matavai la
mienne était à seulement trois jours de
la participation championnat l'union
soviétique
[Musique]
ce que vous voyez là c'est une zone de
64 hectares qui a accueilli toutes les
équipes nationales du rsa c'est
son seul état actuel
dès qu'il n'y a plus de l'activité
humaine si on ne fait rien la nature
reprend ses droits
vous pouvez entendre les loups hurler
ici la nuit
je n'aurais jamais imaginé que l'urss
s'effondrera
[Musique]
tout a commencé en 1989 les premiers
affrontements entre la géorgie et
l'abkhazie ont éclaté et depuis lors
nous sommes séparés dans tous les
domaines sport université télévision
humoristique est utile et vie digne
avec toutes ces attitudes nationaliste
en géorgie et en abkhazie
nous avons dû créer l'université des
tables case la télévision de cases le
football à gaz etc à presque fou le mot
dans la capitale tbilissi on pouvait
entendre de plus en plus souvent des
slogans comme la géorgie au géorgien on
ne pouvait parler que le géorgien et
seuls les géorgiens étaient autorisés à
occuper des postes de direction dans ces
circonstances les petits groupes
ethniques de cette république
caucasienne avait peu d'options accepté
d'être désormais géorgien partir ou se
battra on était à deux doigts de la
guerre c'était évident le nationalisme
se faisaient sentir partout
la géorgie a commencé à sérieusement
parler de sécession elle se préparait à
se séparer de moscou en en ont la quasi
avec elle les abkhazes était contre la
guerre était proche
le 14 août 1992 à 10 heures environ
j'étais en vacances je suis allé à la
plage avec ma valise pour prendre un
café avant de partir pour l'aéroport
c'est dans cette direction là des gars
ont accouru et on dit écoutez il y à des
combats à la barre j'ai dit comment ça
c'est impossible nos défenses se sont
déplacés de la périphérie vers ici à
gauche à droite et au centre pour tenir
le pont rouge et le pont blanc ainsi que
la rue de chambre
[Musique]
ouais
tiendront ils ont détruit notre théâtre
ils ont tout détruit je brûlais
l'atelier sur son genou
quoi d'autre pour la maison aussi
notre sa main le ressentiment des
entités ethniques s'est accumulée au
cours des décennies
ces sentiments avait été réprimée
pendant tout ce temps refoulant cette
maladie c'est traumatisme en profondeur
et n'y a
hélas nous arrivions pour ainsi dire au
point culminant
pénates
chaque république s'est regardé à
travers le prisme de l'histoire
les documents et des faits historiques
ont remonté des profondeurs
si on a commencé à analyser
le pays a été mise en mouvement
le bureau central de l'union soviétique
ne semblait pas se rendre compte qu'il
avait ouvert la boîte de pandore dans
chaque république les nationalistes ont
commencé à exiger l'indépendance il a
fallu un certain temps à moscou pour
décider comment réagir face aux
séparatistes et mettre fin aux conflits
ethniques et qui avait éclaté
simultanément dans le caucase et en asie
centrale
nach
initier des effusions de sang en russie
les affrontements interethniques faisait
rage des conflits causés par des
facteurs raciaux nationaux
boli peut-on oublier que c'est sous
gorbatchev a dit un demi million
d'arméniens ont été expulsés
d'azerbaïjan et que des dizaines de
milliers ont été sauvagement assassinés
des gens ont été brûlés dans leur
voiture je le sais n'était ce pas ce
gorbatchev que les soulèvement anti
russe au kazakhstan et un massacre dans
la vallée de ferghana ont eu lieu
on ne sait pas comment mettre fin à un
conflit sanglant entre peuples il est né
autrement que par la loi et la force
zaccone et chine
si nous avions mis un terme ne serait ce
qu'une seule fois à ceinturer l'intérêt
smic
qui sont toujours provoqué par des
politiciens qui tentent de se servir de
ces conflits pour prendre le pouvoir
rien de tout cela ne serait arrivé chez
nous
gorbatchev ferma les yeux sur certaines
manifestations et ordonna dans réprimer
d'autres les manifestations à bas coût
et à tbilissi ont été violemment
dispersés en janvier 1991 moscou a tenté
une dernière fois de réaffirmer son
influence dans les pays baltes et des
forces spéciales ont été envoyés à
vilnius la capitale lituanienne et ont
reçu l'ordre d'expulser les
nationalistes du centre de télévision
ce casque est utilisé depuis plus de 40
ans
il a sauvé de nombreuses vies en
afghanistan et dans des opérations
menées sur le territoire de l'union
soviétique
c'est notre tâche était la suivante la
télévision et la radio était totalement
sous le contrôle des nationalistes de
sai ou dix ans conspué les chaînes
centrale était basé à moscou mais rien
n'était diffusé en russie donc tous ceux
qui étaient diffusées étaient contre le
gouvernement central
donc nous avons reçu la tâche de libérer
le centre de télévision et la tour de
télévision afin de rendre possible la
diffusion des programmes en russe
avec la participation de journalistes
envoyés de moscow
la division de vilnius était censée
organiser un couloir pour nous selon le
plan deux chars devait arriver est tiré
à blanc jusqu'à trois fois pour
disperser la foule
mais ça n'a pas marché la foule restée
là pourquoi tout simplement parce que
ceux qui avaient organisé tout cela on
dit les soldats et les officiers n'ont
pas de munitions ils n'ont que des
balles à blanc vous voyez ces chars il
tire aussi à blanc
restez où vous êtes
ne vous dispersez pas les gens ne se
sont pas dispersés mais des images des
forces spéciales soviétiques essayant de
disperser la foule se sont vite répandue
dans le monde entier
des coups de feu ont été tirés et
probablement pas seulement par les
forces spéciales les deux camps ont subi
les pertes plus tard moscou c'est à dire
gorbatchev affirma qu'il n'avait pas
donné l'ordre de recourir à la force la
faute serait rachetée sur les officiers
commandants
je ne pouvais pas prendre deux avions et
m'ont volé à vilnius comme ça
gorbatchev était au courant en
1991 la situation est devenue
complètement incontrôlable gorbatchev a
annoncé qu'un référendum se tiendrait au
printemps et il a demandé aux citoyens
soviétiques de voter sur le fait de
savoir si l'état devait être conservé
tel quel
naturellement le référendum a eu lieu et
la majorité de la population à voter
pour l'union soviétique ça use ça use
[Musique]
je
la transnistrie est une étroite bande de
terre le long de la rive du nil est re à
l'époque soviétique elle faisait partie
de la république socialiste soviétique
de moldavie à la fin des années 80 le
vent du changement a soufflé sur qui
chine hao et les nationalistes locaux
ont réclamé l'adoption de l'alphabet
latin et du romain la population
majoritairement russes de transnistrie
s'y est opposée tiraspol sa capitale a
déclaré refuser de faire sécession de
l'urss
la moldavie était encore soviétique à la
fin des années 80 mais ils ont
soudainement décidé de devenir roumain à
des slogans nationalistes ont commencé à
apparaître du genre les russes au delà
de deux nièces et les juifs dans le
deuil est valises train russie
ataman il n'y a eu aucun incident à
signaler
tout à commencer par la langue pour
creuser un fossé entre les peuples ils
ont dû supprimer la seule chose que tout
le monde avait en commun qui unissent et
les gens
la langue utilisée pour la communication
interethniques et c'était le russe il y
a eu des grèves les gens exiger
l'égalité des droits et des chances les
gens ne voulaient pas utiliser
l'alphabet latin les premiers combats
avec les premières victimes militaires
ont eu lieu en 1990
à l'époque du moscou considérait cela
comme un conflit interne toutes les
informations provenaient de chisinau ils
exprimaient leur point de vue disait
qu'il y avait des séparatistes et qu'il
essayait de rétablir l'ordre
constitutionnel
mais quand le sang a été versé pour la
première fois cela a déclenché une
réaction en chaîne qui a conduit à 1992
ce que c'était de faire la guerre et à
quoi ressemblait ces combats je vais
vous raconter dans ce bâtiment en 1992
j'étais ici dans la caserne et là bas
j'avais ma belle mère une jeune épouse
et un enfant d'un an il avait eu un an
le 13 et les combats ont commencé le 19
et nous avons organisé un hôpital au
quatrième étage les blessés ils ont été
transportés
on a allumé un feu sur le balcon pour
pouvoir cuisiner et puis il fallait
également nourrir l'enfant on a lancé un
appel les gens apportaient du lait
condensé
une fois j'ai couru dehors j'avais le
bébé là et dans l'autre main fusils
d'assaut et là bas des cadavres il
pouvait voir qu'il y avait des civils
ici strauss kahn mais ils ont quand même
ouvert le feu et j'ai dû riposter en
tenant mon bébé voilà c'était comme ça
[Musique]
la moldavie nous considèrent comme
séparatiste mais je ne suis pas d'accord
avec cela parce que l'union soviétique
s'est dissoute en 1991 et la
transnistrie a été créée en 1990 dans le
cadre de l'urss dont elle faisait partie
nous ne voulions pas nous séparer nous
étions pour l'union mais la moldavie
avait un autre point de vue nous n'avons
pas fait sécession ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que la transnistrie
n'a jamais quitté l'union soviétique
si les républiques baltes l'arménie et
la géorgie se sont toutes rejointe à la
moldavie pour boycotter le référendum
annoncé par gorbatchev la majorité des
citoyens soviétiques ont voté pour
préserver l' urss
mais le président soviétique s'est rendu
compte que le moment était venu de
changer le format des relations entre le
gouvernement central et les républiques
il a proclamé que la rédaction d'un
nouveau traité d'union étaient en cours
et devaient être signés le 20 août 1991
que nous ayons rédiger un nouveau traité
de l'union qui sera bientôt signée est
déjà un fait de la chose s'attaquent aux
vaisseaux machette 6-1 foule était
apparu avait réussi à provoquer la
dissolution du pays
ce serait une tragédie pour la nation
pour le monde entier et pour les
européens où
il est c'est tout simplement impensable
oui c'est moi
[Musique]
on n'a pas assez d'altitude pour changer
la trajectoire on met au point de non
retour on approche rapidement du sol
vous entendez des signaux d'alarmé mais
c'est déjà trop tard tout est fini
la danse des petits signes du célèbre
lac des cygnes de tchaïkovski est
devenue la bande-son de l'effondrement
de l'union soviétique
c'est ce que toutes les chaînes de
télévision du pays diffusait le matin du
19 août plus tard lé présentateur de la
télévision centrale ont donné lecture
d'une déclaration de membres d'une
organisation appelée le comité national
d'état d'urgence
celui-ci noise manche numéraire
gorbatchev est incapable d'exercer ses
fonctions en tant que président de
l'urss pour des raisons de santé
le vice-président et nayef a assumé les
fonctions de président de l'urss
le pays était en pleine crise des
émeutes de la faim ont commencé des
bagarres dans les queues une pénurie
totale de biens de consommation et le
président du pays nous dit adieu et
s'envole pour fort aux pour se reposer
et se soigner c'est à ce moment là que
nous avons réalisé qu'on ne pouvait plus
attendre
roger ninja
[Musique]
c'est le bureau de mireille gorbatchev
il n'y a pas eu de changements depuis
son poste de travail son bureau
voilà la table où il y avait le
téléphone qui a été débranché le 18 à 16
heures cette chanson
aviez-vous peur vraiment et c'est mieux
pour ma famille oui je sais bien sûr
j'ai aussi pensé que ce n'était pas
seulement ma famille qui pouvaient être
touchés et qu'il y aurait du sens sans
doute
surtout dans un pays aussi grand que le
nôtre et avec tous et ça commence
toujours lentement il a été déclenché
alors c'est difficile à arrêter
difficile à contrôler winnie covo police
où nous n'étions pas guidée par la
logique du complot la logique d'un coup
d'état nous avions supposé que
gorbatchev reviendrai dans un mois et
donc nous lui avons dit monsieur le
président soignez vous pendant un mois
nous vous connaissons nous ne vous
abandonnerons jamais nous croyons en
vous restez là bas un moment reposez
vous possédez odeurs
le comité national d'état d'urgence qui
a déclaré gorbatchev malades et l'a
confiné dans sa datcha à foros était
composé de chefs des organes de sécurité
et de haut fonctionnaire soviétique
il croyait que la pérestroïka était dans
une impasse et que les forces pouvoir
conduisait le pays à l'effondrement
outre le fait d'écarter le président du
pouvoir leur plan consistait à imposer
la censure interdire les rassemblements
de masse et dissoudre tous les partis
politiques les troupes ont été envoyés à
moscou
pourquoi ne m'as-tu pas prévenu à
l'avance je ne serais pas venu je ne
suis pas venu ici depuis le 4 octobre
1993 que je suis
pas une seule fois puis sinon par
principe
vous vous souvenez de ce que vous avez
fait le 19 bien sûr que je m'en souviens
je ne suis pas amnésiques on assiste en
est arrivé à 6 heures du matin il a dit
alexandre nous devons aller au comité
national d'urgence immédiatement nous
sommes arrivés ici exactement une heure
plus tard à 7 heures du matin on était
là tous les dirigeants du mouvement pro
démocratie avec helsinn à sa tête ont
convergé vers la maison blanche
on voulait mettre altin dans une autre
voiture mais il a dit non et nous y
sommes allés avec un drapeau il a refusé
de porter un gilet pare-balles
lui a posé un simple gilet militaire
pour fournir une protection si quelqu'un
commence à tirer sur les vitres sur
notre chemin nous avons dépassé les
colonnes de chars et de véhicules
blindés de transport de troupes et ce
qui était dessus nous faisait des signes
cette junte qui est arrivé au pouvoir
ils savent que s'ils perdent ils ne
perdront pas seulement leur siège mais
seront traduits en justice
[Musique]
la maison blanche est devenu le centre
de la résistance au coup d'état les
partisans de helsinn s'y sont rassemblés
en masse
nous sommes arrivés ici là sur le pont
il y avait des chars il y avait aussi du
matériel militaire ici il n'y avait pas
de clôture mais il y avait une chaîne
humaine et ces gens étaient prêts à tout
il aurait préféré être écrasé par des
sharks de fuir aujourd'hui encore j'ai
les larmes aux yeux quand je pense à
leur héroïsme
il était notre seul espoir
salut
alexei j'allais en forme ça lui
reconnaît les lieux de la gloire
militaire
nous avions entendu dire que le cagibi
voulait arrêter le gouvernement
c'est-à-dire gorbatchev et autres et
nous nous sommes dresser pour défendre
le gouvernement
quelqu'un a dit former des compagnies
200 personnes et moi j'ai dit compagnie
mettez-vous en rang et tous ceux qui
voulaient le faire ont formé une ligne
nous avons formé une chaîne humaine
comme ça tout le monde connaître son
voisin regarder toute la chaîne oui oui
et je gardais l'entrée principale en
tant que commandant d'unités
j'ai regardé les vidéos d'archivés afin
de venir ici tout le monde avait l'air
si inspiré bien sûr il y avait tant
d'espoirs et d'émotion mais la question
est 'que espérions nous
tous on était plein d'espoir que c'était
la fin du pouvoir soviétique que tout
serait merveilleux désormais tout le
quatrième jour on nous a dit que le
groupe alpha allait prendre d'assaut le
bâtiment
nous avons pris position devant les
escaliers et j'ai dit garder les bras
ouverts vous ne devez rien à voir dans
vos mains parce que je savais que si les
alfa venait il serait impossible de les
arrêter et si nos mains n'étaient pas
vides cela pouvait signifier la mort
d'un jeune à mieux même le moindre
soupçon les chars oui je pouvais vous
faire contre alpha avec l'eau achète et
vos pelles
s'effondrer
cette nuit-là a été la plus dure
les véhicules blindés étaient déjà sur
le boulevard qui entoure le centre-ville
on craignait que le bâtiment ne soit
pris
mais aucune attaque n'a eu lieu les
commandants des forces spéciales se sont
probablement soutenue de qui avait été
désignée bouc émissaire après les
événements de vilnius et ont décidé de
ne pas prendre d'assaut la maison
blanche mais des véhicules militaires
étaient toujours déployées dans le
centre de moscou boris eltsine a donc
pris l'une des décisions les plus
importantes de sa carrière politique il
est monté sur un char stationnée devant
la maison blanche
certaines taxes et bien donnez moi le
texte de notre déclaration givet à quoi
zielinski instincts d'animal politique
ce fut un moment historique
staline
le président de la nouvelle russie
grimpe sur un char sur ce qui était un
symbole d'un système totalitaire et
militarisé
élit un manifeste de désobéissance
contre le maladie ce taux
en quelques minutes cette tragédie le
drame du comité national de l'état
d'urgence c'est terminé son sort a été
scellé
[Musique]
les dirigeants du comité national d'état
d'urgence eux-mêmes semblait hésitant et
désemparés à la conférence de presse
qu'ils ont organisée a été un désastre
en terme de relations publiques où se
trouve venir à el ghorba tiers
de quelle maladie souffre utile
et verts qui sont pointés les canons des
sharks nous voyons aujourd'hui dans les
rues de moscou
la conférence de presse était accablante
et une journaliste donne des avis et
maya gazeta tatiana malkin a qui avait
18 ans a posé une question est ce que
vous comprenez que vous avez effectué un
coup d'état cette nuit son schiesser les
mains de ianaïev tremblay et il est
devenu évident que l'on pouvait et
devait le respectable pendant ce temps
alexandre haut de ce col adjoint
d'eltsine et vice président de la russie
a contre toute attente réussi à
s'envoler de moscou pour foros il a pu
entrer dans la résistance de gorbatchev
et rencontrer le dirigeant soviétique
doudaïev le ministre de l'intérieur m'a
donné 20 personnes et nous nous sommes
envolés ensemble pour forum
donc je suis rentré et il est venu à ma
rencontre pour me souhaiter la bienvenue
à cause du poids puis j'ai vu reiss à
descendre en pleurant elle a dit j'ai
pensé qu'ils étaient venus pour nous
arrêter mais dès que je vous ai vus j'ai
compris que tout allait bien dieu merci
et donc j'ai dit à gorbatchev qu'avez
vous fait il était confus et plus j'ai
vu le téléphone j'ai décroché compris
que ça fonctionnait j'ai demandé à
l'opératrice de me passer elle signer ce
qu'elle a fait voilà je lui ai dit que
j'étais là avec gorbatchev qu'il était
sur place lui aussi et que je prendrai
un avion pour moscou dans deux heures
à l'époque beaucoup se demandaient si
gorbatchev était au courant ont
soupçonné un coup d'état ou s'il était
lui-même à l'origine du comité national
d'état d'urgence
shozna gorbatchev savez tout quand
certains hauts fonctionnaires du parti
sont venus le voir à foros et ont
suggéré qu'on déclare l'état d'urgence
il 10
j'imagine à peu près qui fait partie de
votre comité national d'état d'urgence
lumière plus de style sheet bien et il a
écrit tous les noms après cela il a dit
ne plus sauf sur gvt hoymille vous savez
je ne peux pas faire ça avec vous
déclarer l'état d'urgence
alors tant pis c'est beau diable
je suis certaine qu'il n'en savait rien
n' y participer pas ce fut une tragédie
pour lui et sa femme je connaissais très
bien mais elle sergueïevitch et raïssa
maximum n'a je sais que pour elle ça a
été l'un des pires moments de sa vie
parce qu'il savait tout les 2 comment
cela aurait pu se terminer contre le
coup d'état échoué
les conspirateurs ont été arrêtés et le
ministre de l'intérieur boris pougo
s'est suicidé un état cesse d'exister
une fois qu'il devient ingouvernable
et le comité national d'état d'urgence
est apparu quand cette situation était
absolument incontrôlable parce que des
personnes pour ainsi dire un peu
professionnelle comme il ya nayef par
exemple ont soudainement prix sera un
fardeau qui était trop lourd no show ni
voici le il ya choose to me
sens toute ma responsabilité vis-à-vis
des gens parce que je n'ai pas su
préserver l'union soviétique konygnski
soyouz
school même si cela peut sembler plutôt
ambitieux de ma part aujourd'hui je me
sens coupable vis-à-vis du peuple parce
que j'ai échoué à sauver le pays
[Musique]
il
la forêt de bélouve est une immense
réserve naturelle situés des deux côtés
de la frontière entre la biélorussie et
la pologne à l'époque soviétique une
résidence du gouvernement s'y trouvaient
et c'est là que les dirigeants des trois
pays la russie l'ukraine et la
biélorussie se sont réunis début
décembre 1991 à la forêt de belvèze et
le lieu où l'union soviétique a
officiellement cessé d'exister
le 8 décembre des événements historiques
se sont déroulés ici avec l'accord de
bello vais-je
la réunion n'était pas secret pour la
visite officielle de helsinn a commencé
le 6 décembre
il est intéressant de voir comment tout
a été planifié dans le cadre du
processus de novo ogaryovo les
dirigeants des neuf république
soviétique restantes devait signer un
traité créant une nouvelle union d'états
souverains
et il voulait se rencontrer sans corps
batch et
stanislav chouchkevitch qui était
récemment devenu président du soviet
suprême de la république de biélorussie
avait besoin de renforcer sa crédibilité
il voulait donc invitées elles tine en
biélorussie
le 8 décembre nous étions à un moment
clé
le 1er décembre l'ukraine avait organisé
un référendum sur la souveraineté et
l'indépendance
son unité pizzas smst
le 1er décembre leur peuple a élu leonid
kravtchouk
qui est devenu le premier président
ukrainien ne m'en cache pas
boris elstine m'a adressé la parole à
vélo vais-je
il a dit mikhaïl sergueïevitch m'a
chargé de vous poser cette question
est-ce que l'ukraine acceptera de signer
le nouveau traité de l'union si c'est
soit été prise en compte dans un
amendement à cet accord
je lui ai dit que nous avions tenu à
référendum
et que le peuple ukrainien avait dit non
nous allons construire une ukraine
indépendante
[Musique]
helsinn a ouvert la réunion en posant la
question de gorbatchev à kraft chioukh
l'ukraine se joindre à t-elle au nouveau
traité d'union
bourbeau lice a ensuite sorti un
document de sa poche et à commencé à le
lire sans le montrer aux autres
participants aux négociations
les partis qui ont convenu chez
la biélorussie la russie et l'ukraine de
créer l'urss en 1922
sayos c'est
cac subit constate maintenant que
l'union soviétique et a pas les pics en
tant que sujet de droit international et
réalités géopolitiques cesse d'exister
tout le monde était d'accord même si
tout ce qui évite ch se souvient qu'au
début tout le monde était stupéfié comme
et dès que cela a été convenu il est
devenu plus facile de discuter
officiellement gorbatchev qui n'a pas
été invitée à belvèze et est toujours
chef de l'état il y avait des agents du
kgb et des militaires tout autour de la
résidence
il aurait ordonné d'arrêter tous ceux
qui étaient réunis mais le président
soviétique ne l'a pas fait il a
simplement écouté les rapports des
présidents de la russie de l'ukraine et
de la biélorussie par téléphone
nous avons appelé gorbatchev il n'a pas
répondu alors nous avons décidé
d'appeler bouche pendant que nous
attendions
mais une fois que nous en avons convenu
nous avons reçu un appel de gorbatchev
aucun mot inadéquat n'a été prononcée
les il était critique et nous a lancé un
reproche vous agissez comme des enfants
que va dire la communauté internationale
je lui ai dit que l usine était au
téléphone avec bush et que ce dernier
prenait les choses de manière positive
et aux instruments
les négociations étaient encore en cours
dans la salle de billard 10 vers une
heure du matin de grandes tables
blanches étaient posées ici pour la
cérémonie de signature des accords
après la fin des négociations lorsqu'il
est devenu clair que nazarbaïev ne
viendrait pas ils se sont tous assis
dans cette zone a redit ce bourg bolis
helsinn québec djokovic kravtchouk ils
vous regardent et fokine puis la
cérémonie de signature a eu lieu dans le
respect de toutes les règles
diplomatiques
tout a été préparé par le service du
protocole du président russe victor
iliouchine était là aussi ils se sont
serré la main et puis ils ont rédigé une
déclaration pour la presse tout le monde
était de bonne humeur l'ambiance était
presque euphorique
mon
là
pour certains la dissolution de l'union
soviétique a été le début d'une ère de
liberté
pourquoi personne ne s'est levé pour
défendre l'union soviétique pour
défendre croit la pauvreté et l'absence
de liberté que les gens avaient enduré
pendant des années il n'y avait pas
beaucoup d'enthousiaste
pour d'autres la destruction de l'urss a
été la plus grande catastrophe de leur
vie
[Musique]
nous sommes dans le village minier dakar
marc à il fait partie de la région de
thouars tchale ici vivaient des mineurs
et leurs familles il y avait des mines
radieuses charte et non loin d'ici
il y avait huit minutes qui était
opérationnel à différentes époques leur
production totale de charbon était de
plus de 500 mille tonnes par an ce
village bouillonnait de vie on peut dire
dans ce cas
voilà à quoi ressemble trente ans après
la fin de l'union soviétique une
tentative de construire le socialisme
dans un petit village de montagne
tout est en ruine maintenant après
l'effondrement de l'union soviétique
les mines ont été fermés parce que les
liens économiques ont été rompues
évidemment
on avait plus besoin de charbon alors
les mines l'élément essentiel de la
région n'avait plus aucun rôle à jouer
[Musique]
bien sûr que c'est triste il y à un
immeuble de plusieurs étages en face de
nous les gens qui ont vécu leur vie ils
élevaient leurs enfants ici les enfants
allaient à l'école tout est délabré
maintenant il ne me reste plus que mille
personnes environ
[Musique]
le village était prospère à l'époque il
y avait tout un restaurant un grand
magasin un hôtel un hôpital et quel
hôpital c'était les meilleurs médecins
d'abkhazie travail est ici
[Musique]
début 1994 beaucoup de gens sont partis
ils ont dit si vous avez un endroit où
aller prenez ce que vous pouvez document
effets personnels bijoux rien d'autre
c'est triste
on avait le sentiment que tout s'était
effondré
un tel pays ne pouvait être détruit que
de l'intérieur un tel effondrement était
évitable si gorbatchev avait été plus
résolue il aurait pu au moins mieux
gérer la situation
pour moi c'était une tragédie optimiste
pied stran tous les pays de l'urss ont
été ramenés au moins trente ans en
arrière dans leur développement
historique
l'accord de bello neige n'a pas
démanteler l'union soviétique à il a
fait en sorte que cet effondrement soit
un processus civilisé et sans compliquer
la dissolution est un terme qui relève
de la chimie ce qui s'est passé c'est
une destruction ou l'ingénieur